hey what's up guys i'm qbhd here and
these are the new bose noise canceling
headphones
700.
terrible name that might be the worst
thing about these headphones so when i
first saw that bose announced these they
kind of took me by surprise but the more
you think about them and use them the
more it makes perfect sense these are a
prime example of competition driving
things forward and making better
products for us the consumers you'll see
what i mean so the most striking part is
of course the new pretty minimal design
i don't love it i mean it's definitely a
unique look it looks fine i think the
look they're going for here is minimal
and clean
but i like that they're still matte
black everything there's also a silver
version i like that it's pretty
lightweight still and i like that
they're still over ear but they've kind
of seemingly gotten rid of any visible
hinges or any broken lines at all it
just kind of looks like these smooth ear
cups attached to one single stock but
you can still rotate them around and it
still gives you pretty much a hundred
percent of the flexibility you had
before the top band is still soft and
the clamp force is still pretty solid
you put them on and even before turning
them on they've created a nice seal it's
just definitely a very unique look i
think the only thing i really don't like
even though i totally get it is the
adjustability for height as you can see
is now just this smooth slide instead of
the clicks you usually get from like
every other pair of headphones so this
is less satisfying but you know it makes
sense with this really smooth minimal
look but then pretty much all the new
features that they've added are a direct
response to all the headphones that have
been coming out over the past year that
have had all kinds of cool features that
have sort of passed them up like if you
look back the bose qc series that iconic
quietcomfort headphone lineup has been
kind of the same almost stubbornly for
the past couple years even as we evolved
just because they kind of settled in as
the industry standard people knew that
if you wanted noise cancelling
headphones you just got those but then
along came the microsoft surface
headphones and the sony xm3s and just a
bunch of others in the last year that
really had all these crazy 2019 features
that started to i think actually eat
into their sales so they had to respond
so now these new features we get in the
700s i'm just calling them the 700s uh
many of these new features are just
straight from what we just got in this
new competition so the 700s now finally
have usb type c where all the quiet
comforts were micro usb uh these will
now also they'll connect to two
different bluetooth devices at once and
can instantly swap back and forth
between them love that you now have also
a touchpad on the side of the right
headphone with media controls so double
tap the touchpad to play and pause
swipe up or swipe down to change the
volume up or down and swipe forward to
go forward swipe backward to go back
it's not cold enough for me to test if
these like stop working when it's cold
or anything like that but they seem to
work pretty great now and then there are
three physical buttons so on the right
side there's the power slash bluetooth
button so single tap turns it on and off
and a long press goes to pairing mode
and then the second button over here is
your assistant button so you tap it and
it'll pause your music and use the
excellent built-in mics to let you ask
google assistant things and then on the
left side is a noise cancellation
adjustment button so you can cycle
between a maximum of 10 out of 10
5 out of 10 or 0 out of 10 noise
cancellation and those presets are
customizable and then the bose music app
is all fresh and clean and it'll tell
you exactly how much battery you have
left to the minute and it'll let you
dial in any noise cancellation level
from 1 to 10 at any time which is super
specific and you can change what
assistant the assistant button triggers
so if you have a samsung phone you can
do bixby maybe you want alexa maybe you
want siri that's your call what that
bose app notably doesn't have is any
sort of eq control so if you're someone
who wants to have that extra bass or you
want to add to messing with the way it
sounds out the box these don't do it
from the bose app and i'll say these
sound just about as high quality as any
bluetooth headphones have been
and their sound signature the way they
sound is unsurprisingly kind of flat
like that's just the way both headphones
have sounded for the past couple years
with the quiet comforts if you're in it
for that big thumping bass you might
find these a bit lackluster or
disappointing but you're rarely buying
these for the big thumping bass you're
buying them for the noise cancellation
and they definitely deliver on that but
it's not all roses there are a couple
other things to consider that aren't
just upgraded features so like i
mentioned it has usb type c which is
great but on the other side they have a
2.5 millimeter headphone jack instead of
3.5 so if you run out of battery or you
want to plug in wired audio for some
reason
you have to use i guess their included
2.5 millimeter to 3.5 millimeter cable
instead of any old regular audio cable
that you have ready to go that's kind of
disappointing the case also compared to
the competition is decently compact but
not the smallest i think the sony's
would win again for smallest overall
travel size because they actually fold
but the bose case does have this neat
magnetic flap covering the pocket to put
in the cables so that's pretty cool but
i also noticed it doesn't come with the
airline adapter anymore this is the one
that came with the sony's and they've
come with bose quiet comfort ones in the
past and i feel like just including this
made me remember that this was like the
default headphones that you listen to on
a plane
but they're not included with the 700s i
don't know maybe they just assume you
already have one overall though just as
a package
this is the upgrade that we've been
waiting for from bose the sleeping giant
of noise canceling headphones finally
got poked enough times into making a
move and delivering this a better
overall product in pretty much every
possible way from the previous
generation it's better for us so the
natural question a lot of you probably
wondering is these or the sonys the mark
iii's that i recently have claimed and a
lot of people agree are pretty much the
king of noise-cancelling headphones now
which would you pick and there's a lot
of good reasons now for each of them but
here's what i will say the sonys are
lighter because of their plastic
they also fold down smaller better for
traveling longer battery life and
they're 50 dollars cheaper but if you're
buying headphones for noise cancellation
the bose are back on top as far as
actual quality of noise cancellation the
quality of the built-in mics is
incredible and the overall build quality
of the bose headphones is superior so
for the money the sony might be a little
bit of a better buy plus i prefer the
sound from these with a little more
character a little more fun
um but i'm glad the competition has
brought us yet another incredible choice
that's what you get for having better
products around so companies compete
we win
there it is
hey thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
you